all right
back at it again
how's everyone doing
I'm tired
it's only 10 30 P.M
but
I would much like to go to sleep
ah
can you get an overview of your progress
um yeah
I guess
uh basically you spawn in
the world is somewhat randomly generated
um you're spawn in
and you need to go to
this tent
and uh sorry I'm not trying my screen
that's how tired I am
all right so the world is somewhat
randomly generated
um you basically spawn in
let's find an better
world now they're all quite sporadic or
um that one wasn't bad all right and you
need to go to the tent
so you go to this tent and there's some
coffee
uh that you can pick up and there's a
gun that you can pick up
um
uh
and then there'll be enemies that appear
which at the moment don't
um
and they'll shoot you and you can Target
them with right Mouse button and that
little Target means that it's snapping
onto
that enemy so you can kind of
shoot them and here I am
shooting them
um we'll run out of ammo eventually but
I can pick up their guns
um
foreign
that's like oh my God this is all rifle
so basically you've got the coffee I
mean I'm dead because you can see the
coffee's empty but it was
wasn't quite empty so if I turn off the
enemy spawning actually won't be on here
basically you get the coffee
and then once you have the coffee so you
can see here it's
full
you need to go to deliver it to the
general and so you have to go all the
way to wherever this Arrow points
and this is the general stand which at
the moment looks the same but will be
different
and it won't have the coffee here or the
gun
um and then that's the game they have to
deliver it there
yeah the ammo text is not that's just a
debug text that's not gonna happen
that's not gonna be like that
um
yeah
so I have to deliver the coffee
basically to this General tent
and this box are also kind of temporary
and the world is basically infinite
well no it's not infinite
but it it is like very big
and very boring
but that's that's it
if I can get to the end
oh I got to the hunt
that's the end of the world
no
all right any questions
what happened to the Crosshair the
crosshairs only a few uh are targeting
enemies
so if you hold right click
and you're actually pointing towards an
enemy at the moment it's even if you
don't have a gun but if you hold right
click and you're like pointing towards
an enemy Within
a decent angle
um
then
you can shoot
at them and that's what this is this is
just showing you which enemy it's
targeting
those enemies are trying to shoot me but
they're just shooting
not me and this guy is like facing the
other way somehow
all right man
he just fell on his face
um
yeah how does the coffee spill yeah when
you get hit
the coffee spills so if I pick up the
coffee
um and then let's try and spawn maybe
like one in one enemy
no that didn't spawn anyone
there you go
then see
as he shoots me
I'm losing coffee and you can see the
level go down
um now I I don't know if
aiming works
vertically as well
it should
I mean maybe
it should be normalized though
um so I'm kind of gonna probably work on
enemies for a bit because they don't
they're a bit weird
foreign
so like let me see if I can kill him
see I'm hitting that thing though
why am I not shooting him
like that's wrong
somehow
ah well I mean I guess it's because
all right but that's fine
let's move this here
uh let me just make it so that
I can just spawn
uh
say F4
we'll just spawn an enemy
that doesn't work
August spawn is false
why did that Spawn Two
okay let's keep press not key
down
I guess I could just do it and release
I feel like pressed should the first
frame yeah
that's a bit weird
oh because they're spawning anyway
I think
yeah whoops right they're not
what the heck why the enemy is spawning
ah
whoops
all right never mind
okay so there's my one enemy
so this is what's going this is the
vector this is how I'm shooting oh
because the origin of the player is that
like really it I think I think it really
has to be from the gun like it really
should be from the gun it could be from
the origin of the gun I guess I wouldn't
really care about that like that can be
that's probably fine
um
like it doesn't matter honestly
and it's fine for the game Jam
so if I look at
um
this
so the shoot origin should probably like
if we don't have a gun
I guess we will return
and if there's no ammo let's just yeah
sure well let's put this block here so
so that we can basically
um
set the shoot origin to be the guns
translation
but we'd probably need to get the
world's translation which is
why this is a bit annoying
uh and then
I guess we can use the play as
translation for this maybe
but then this will be the gun
and that's just gonna move it up a bit
so I don't need a gun now
let's pull an enemy with a four
pick up a gun Maybe
that's weird
so now you can see it's from it's going
from the origin of my gun
to him
now it'd be good if I can I can uh
if I if I go too far out
I can't aim at him
um
that's probably too much though
no I did want to do that actually
why is it so difficult to pick up this
gun
to like jump on the table
foreign
okay that's really weird
it almost looks like it's working like
but it's just backwards but then you get
some weird cases where it's
clearly not working
because that's like this side
oh no no it's because
uh it's relative
um
because it's not an absolute thing
like I said that's not the world
rotation
because it's dependent on the player's
so how would I even do that
or should the player just rotate towards
I guess the player should just rotate
yeah towards like
what if we do that
like if you aim
oh
maybe not
damn I went High
but see how I rotate towards him
that's kind of dope but then I don't
know why that happens
um
I think I should just not
like I should probably zero out the Y
but that does look cool
let's try that
because that this should now just be a
horizontal rotation I think
that's pretty darn I'm not gonna lie
that looks pretty cool
yeah I like that nice
now
um we're also printing yeah why can't I
pick up the gun look I'm on it man I'm
like literally touching it
let's look at the physics cloud is
because I don't know why
because it should be this gun pickup
uh maybe only selected
which is here
and the player
is clearly intersecting it is it not
but I want to move if I do that
that's very strange
I mean we could make this a bit bigger
for the pickup but
that's really weird
whatever Peter can deal with that maybe
because see it works here
look it's working now
but it just wasn't before
oh look now I can't pick up a coffee I
can when I'm here but I know I can
weird
spawn me some enemies
why why is he not dying okay he died
so there needs to be a max range
and the guns need to have range so that
snipers can basically be long distance
right
and there's no accuracy at the moment
either which kind of sucks
yeah it'll be cool if we could slow down
the time step for
when we're aiming downside that would
just be cool I think
will the character remain as a desk I
think so because Tim made a test
as a desk
bro
but now I
think maybe the problem is weren't
intersecting both gone and coffee yeah
probably
um because I think they might be
overlapping
thank you
let's have a look
uh I mean they are I guess they're
overlapping like the slightest amount
like this is them overlapping
yeah look at that
this is demo overlapping very very small
amount
but like I could move the coffee away
from the gun
whether that's like high priority but
sure let's do it
no real problems here
oh actually this is still look grab
assault rifle I'm not intersecting that
am I or is it because the player Collide
is big oh well the player collider is
big but see it's not letting me pick up
the coffee
ah but I have to I think this is just
with how Peter set up the physics events
you have to basically leave it and then
rejoin it I can't move from one to the
other I have to like leave and then
rejoin and then it works
so it's kind of weird but whatever
man this oh this map though
this might be an impossible map
Oh no I got out
oh
that's pretty dope though
I do have to say I like the
um does this this should just pick up
ammo I guess it does though it's the
same time
and it kind of consumes it if it's not
that little red laser stupid
yeah it should probably appear when you
uh
aim or something
what's your opinion of C sharp now
you're my experienced with it I mean I
like I refused to say shot for a while
like back when I worked at EA I used it
a lot
um because all of EA's tools are written
in C sharp like the level editor and
like frosted
and everything is all written in c-sharp
WPF so I use it a lot then as well and I
really like it I always really liked it
the only time maybe I didn't like it as
much is when back in University when I
didn't really use it that much
but yeah
um okay
Yeah Tim you probably could have just
made like a low poly Soldier
yeah like
yeah imagine something like this how
cool would this look
oh
there's time but I'm just saying
like this would be kind of dope
yeah because check this out I'm this
thing
I don't know why the crosshairs here
it's weird oh it's always been beneath
low I think anyway
um
so I made it so that the
I can square enemies where they're for
but basically when you aim it rotates
the player that's so that just makes it
feel so much better that's actually
really nice
and so you can kill him
uh no but the reason why I didn't make a
load poly character like this because of
this what are the things make somebody
cute two legs no arms no I know that
that definitely was the initial idea
but also it wasn't which this does not
feel like it was yeah but you have the
tank traps and you have this ah I
haven't done anything yeah but that's
not going to suddenly make it look like
that is it so what are these sand traps
sandbags
yeah there's a there's even a prefab
yeah oh yeah
so just scatter them around
that's kind of cool and then what was uh
tank traps
traps
so anti-tank traps so they're traps for
anti-tanks
I'm kidding either way it works oh
prefab not valid or whatever yeah right
this Ryan's favorite Company of Heroes
company what Company of Heroes you
haven't played that oh it's an RTS
yeah but I think like if you scattered a
bunch with him I think that could
transform
ER
I won't lie I kind of I kind of like
this gameplay
like come come feel it
I'll just give you infinite ammo
thanks young generous of you so what is
this right click to aim yeah
and you can F4 to spawn on enemies
so when you can't aim you have to kind
of be facing them a little bit to aim at
them
but doesn't that yeah and that's you
can't because it's going through the gun
the gun should Orient towards him as
well that's difficult
yeah because it's right it's it's well I
don't know how difficult it is but it's
it's because it's um
it's uh relative to the player and the
player has a rotation like it's not well
it's
bro
like
yeah I think you're you have to
but also you picked up a shotgun you
have no ammo you should have picked up a
different gun oh and it just these
points yeah
gonna get a gun and then Hammer account
and just drag that out
I think it's because it was going from
the origin
which I need to make the origin the tip
of the gun
as well uh because it's going from the
origin and if the origins back here and
you're behind something yeah yeah do you
need me to explode the mush no no it's
fine
although it would be faster from a
performance standpoint if the origin was
the tip because there is an entity
that's the tip but I have to like I'd
have to like find have a look at the
children yeah I don't know why that
happens as well no no this is what I
meant but I meant like you see how we're
doing recoil yeah we're gonna be able to
do that if I change the origin oh I see
because we'll rotating all right okay
well then it doesn't matter I'll just
make it
yeah it's fine
cool
Skies can be gray but also the the
reason the fog is like this is to hide
the um
well because it's kind of like fog of
War but also to hide the uh
uh the chunks kind of spawning in
which you can kind of see if it's snow
because they're a little bit immersive
and you can see them through the fog
I kind of like the fog
it's nice
oh I can have two coffees
nice the ultimate dream that's because
this tent is not really complete
um all right
foreign
yeah I think crosstair should be uh not
visible by default
okay so I'd like to get like when chunks
get created
I'd like to spawn in enemies
and not even when they get created just
when they get like
set up I think yeah that's a good idea
but not the initial ones
I think that would be good
um
so like
this can probably go away
um
but when we do
set chunk
um we can maybe check to see
that it's not
can spawn enemies
equals true and then we'll just turn
that off
for the very first one for this one
so the tent will be false and false
but otherwise every time you go away
from a chunk and come back to a chunk
within that chunk it can spawn maybe
like
one to three enemies or something I
don't know man
like let's that'll be quick and dirty
and that that'll be kind of fun I think
um
so if can spawn enemies then
basically
spawn
enemy in chunk or something
um
and like we have a chunk index
so we can just look at probably
well actually we can get the chunk can't
we the chunk itself
because what the heck does this do
chunk index yeah there it is
I'll just
re-assert that this is the case
um
this right into his position is correct
right I thought we used that
are we used to maybe use that do we
still
maybe I did get rid of it
but my point was we could probably use
that because that its origin yeah no we
can
um
so that's like the Min and then it'll be
Plus
basically chunk size
um
like the tile width
foreign
[Music]
whatever
hey um
clean he gets his boys to clean it
now of course especially
hahaha
[Music]
but not perfectly right
yeah I guess not
oh
that spawned a lot of enemies
what the heck
I don't want to spawn around the origin
but also why
like this shouldn't happen immediately
right
why did that spawn so many enemies
straight away
oh because it also does that when I move
I forgot about that Old Chestnut
um
but that wire was probably zero
yeah that's right you can't just spawn
them there you have to check the tile
and adjust the Y value
um
yeah just gonna keep spawning like a lot
of them
but also
I guess maybe
like what we could do
is kind of only do it if it's new
then eventually you'd kill everyone
that might be better wow
no that's not better
what the heck
it's fun
what how did it spawn that many did you
guys see that
yeah yes
oh I'm in the for Loop that's hilarious
uh one second
that's really funny
yeah so that's probably that might be
too many especially around spawn I mean
we could just check to see
if they're in a radius where they can
spawn like we could be like hey man
if uh like
Vector 3 dot distance
well actually we could just be
translation length if that's less than
some safe radius
like private
back to three
save from origin radius
uh let's just say you can't spawn Within
20 meters or 50 meters probably too much
30 meters
from the origin or whatever
that way we can make sure that we don't
spawn
so we only got two enemies spawning
there but they I guess they will come
and find you maybe or maybe they
shouldn't come and find you they should
probably just uh
yeah run around okay that's good
um so next up then
will be
um
was it just made a Tim want me to come
over it's kind of gone now so we'll see
but uh
next up was their position their y
position
their y position
so
how do we deal with that
um easy the exploring me chunk once it
finds a translation
for them it needs to get at the tile
at that translation
so I can only spawn them if it's not
null
but additionally we can get the
y of that tile and we can basically set
this y
uh to be tile transaction y plus like
another extra meter or something
and so now they should actually spawn
like
you know above the ground basically but
if I go out further I'll should
encounter more enemies
um there's this enemy container here
that's storing them so I'm just kind of
looking at this to see them like how
many of them are spawning and stuff and
unfortunately I'm not seeing them spawn
so that's not good news
um it might mean that the tile is null
which would be unfortunate
there's nothing in there did you want me
to come over
okay I'll be right back guys
oh that's nice
yeah yeah ship it
all right Tim's tent looks good
the General's tent so why am I not
spawning it's got to be because it's
null
but it shouldn't be
like I'm surprised it is
yeah so it couldn't support enemy
at 31 by 25 because that doesn't
actually exist apparently
really
27 3 doesn't exist
my eyes falling
that's funny poor enemy
um why is that the case
no time no tile is what I meant but um
that's so strange
because this like it should definitely
be here unless I'm just wrong when it
comes to this which actually I now that
I think about it I might be no but I'm
looking at the root entities translation
like this is as real as it gets because
that's actually according to Hazel like
what the entities translation is
and then what am I doing
is this right
I'm going all the way up to up to Max
minus min
that's going to give me a number between
yeah zero and one
that's weird
huh
oh but to be fair this isn't gonna work
for negative is it
oh no I think I think it is actually why
wouldn't it
I am negative here though so let's maybe
go positive
and let's see if it manages to spawn any
enemies
uh yes it is spawning some enemies
but not like it's still not yeah still
not managing too
26 and one
that seems very wrong though because I'm
all the way at 139 so why is it trying
to spawn enemies at basically the origin
of the world what the heck
that's very wrong yeah that's not right
wait
hold your horses the root and the root
entry of the chunk is
always zero
huh
maybe if you look at the first child
you'll see the right
results ah man
I don't think you can look at the
rodenti's translation okay what if we do
this this might be a bit of a hack but
um
like we could see if this works well
that
that worked
yeah I think that works
and see they're above ground so clearly
they're spawning in all right
yeah good
the red entities were all of the origin
that's why
um
I mean that looks like we're spawning in
plenty and I think I might want to
increase the radius
to make it like
kind of like you know maybe don't spawn
too close to home
but where are they
oh that one's falling through the ground
great
yeah it's possible that they sometimes
fall
which is a bit boring uh maybe I could
just make them like spawn in
by doing plus two maybe that would be so
far
but like that radius
uh I guess it's also a vertical thing
well
[Music]
I just want to make it safe for you to
get your stuff
and then be like all right I need to go
this way
to deliver the coffee
all right that's a bit scary oh
I'm out of ammo yeah you need a way to
fight them without like you need to jump
on them or something
um these guns
like the assault rifle
yeah
they have Gun Barrel
S
as well
yeah I guess so but I can I can set that
up that doesn't look the best on the
yellow you know
give me green I can be a yellow light it
can be I don't know I'll I'll figure it
out I guess
yeah just um if you want the green tent
no material default mesh material yeah
okay
what was the first one
okay yeah
so shoot origin is the guns transform
but let's try to do gun dot children
one dot transform but I don't know if
that'll work
it's a bit dodgy
yeah that seems to be
either that's just the wrong one
but why like
why would it be the that side it should
be here
I'm just not sure if it's actually
correct
hmm
this is not fantastic
I don't know if this will make a
difference
uh no it's still from there
so that's super strange
like what the heck
I know I know we're incrementing it a
little bit with the that specific line
oh no actually it's going on it's going
directly from shooter origin
which is the world position basically
like how
how is that wrong
I mean it was the uh assault rifle
but that doesn't really make any sense
does it that's the pickup
see the gun barrel is here
so
which is yeah the positive kind of
Direction
so if that's what where it is
then how is it coming up
then how is it
how is it wrong
hmm
[Music]
that's why something weird happens with
the gun like
it's like sometimes it's
because remember how it goes
because like look at that rotation man
like something is just not correct
what sets the rotation I mean I said it
sometimes but
why is it 18180
I mean it kind of works
but what sets like does is something
setting that
because look I can't control the
position
so something's got to be telling the gun
where to be maybe
oh look
position gun
why why does a gun need to be positioned
[Music]
the gun is the opposite direction to
play because
Peter did some stuff at one point
okay so now it's a bit weird
uh
something's still setting it look I
can't
oh no I can rotate it here
but what's controlling the the X
rotation
okay something's still controlling the X
just the X rotation it seems
why does this gun draw across here oh
that's the yeah the aiming thing okay
oh the gun has its iron
logic which my position I think
there it is rotation that's the only
thing when you shoot
uh on upside look
I guess because they want there's recoil
and all this stuff
okay well let's keep this for now
I did that thing again
that shows explain why
I want
I filed that there
come on
yeah I don't really like that
but I'm trying to diagnose why
why that is completely off
like
it's supposed to be the barrel
yes Hazel can run on Linux we wanted to
ship this on Linux but maybe not day one
and there's Peter's upside down gone
again
actually yeah the red pointer
is pretty much going from the right
place isn't it
so how is that working
oh well it's just
this
I mean that's actually not a bad hack
instead of doing the gun barrel this is
a bit weird though
I don't know if this will quite work but
instead of doing the Gun Barrel
record
just take the gun
transform
while transform forward
like we could just take the forward
vector
of the gun so like as in
the
um I guess we'd need the this
so let's get the world transform
and then move it like a meter forward
like what would that look like
so the pink one is the one I care about
uh where are the enemies are let me just
spawn one
and work
well they're here somewhere
I think it's just a bit hilly so
they're a bit
no that is dumb
but why look it's because the rotation's
like wrong
it doesn't take into account rotation or
something weird like that I don't
understand how that's possible there
because it is the forward Direction
after all
yeah very weird
ah
[Music]
the playlist is um
it's just uh
synth pop
genre on epidemic sound
uh I don't know why this is so difficult
man like it really shouldn't be I just
don't understand why it's not working
but like also look the gun is just like
upside down a lot a lot more now this
used to be more rare
but that's like
I don't know that's Peter did something
like that's Peter Pit the whole gun
situation code is all Peters
so I don't really know
like I want to spend time
foreign
yeah I mean the red line
how is that happening again that's this
draw Crosshair thing
yeah that just happens to be
the translation of the player somehow
plus Direction I understand how that
actually gets you there
uh but also it's doing minus forward why
is it doing minus four maybe I'm going
the wrong way somehow
what if I do minus forward
I mean that that shouldn't work because
it's not like it was backwards
but also yeah that's a bit weird
I mean that's still like again the
rotation it like doesn't it look
I don't know how the red line is working
so well I mean it's again it's good it's
not it's originating at the back though
so it's not really working that well but
it's just using like the player's
translation basically
plus the players forward right
well yeah
ah Direction Why do I have to play with
that
no all this
just the origin
does this work I mean that's gotta work
right
maybe it's just that forward vectors
weird but that doesn't make much sense
either
like see that's also getting more and
more
like right or whatever
that's so weird
since I'm doing something ridiculous I
don't understand why that's happening
um but actually
I already found me
stop spilling my coffee
where's my where's the gun
because I was gonna say the gun no but
the gun does have a static mesh
so this is actually the
well because I thought maybe it was a
sub thing but it's not
people
yeah this is not this is nuts I really
don't know why this isn't working I
think it's something to do with the
weird I do still think it's something to
do with the weird rotation that pet is
doing which I don't really understand
and I don't want to waste time on that
so maybe we can just leave this for
Peter
to figure out
and for now we can just maybe use
like
just the player's translation
I don't know I'm out out of this space
again
oh Peter
I'm so sick of Peter's jolts things
nice
so now it's like the ground
oh because well yeah that is the
player's origin
so what happens if we just
take this like again if we just fudge it
so if we do plus new Vector three so if
we lift it up like a meter
again it's weird that we have to do this
but
and then
shift it like
right
why is this not work huh
it does work it's just stupid
[Music]
um
so we take it up a little bit we take it
right a little bit and we take it
forward a little bit based on the player
so that's gonna be a bit slow well not
ideal but
no well that's wrong
it almost looks like it should be minus
both of those
because for I don't know what this is
very weird I'm gonna have to do a bit of
a deep dive on this after the jam
like in terms of Hazels and
what the heck Hazel is doing because
it's a bit weird
where are the enemies at can I spawn a
few
I don't know if that still works
maybe it does maybe it's just spawning
them not in the right place
any of them no they're all falling
through the ground man
why does this sometimes happen
and that doesn't really seem to work
anymore
all right
it's not quite right
let's just leave it as I leave it at
that
okay so this is obviously now
originating from the middle of us which
is a bit weird
but it's
probably okay
what is he
why is he missing him
that looks like a direct hit
ah
okay I want to get rid of a couple
things I'm gonna get rid of this stupid
thing
and this draw Crosshair like let's not
do that
I'm wearing that Crosshair and across
there I mean that red line that Peter
did
we won't do that
so understand why half of them fall
through the ground like we we're
supposed to be getting the tile that
they're on
the guns backwards
foreign
we don't have a way to slow the time
step down do we
threw Hazel at the moment through C
sharp
I don't even know where that would be
um
uh
yeah do we do that I mean I guess I
think it would be cool
um so let's let's just do this because I
think whatever like I don't really care
what this game turns out to be it's just
I just want it to be cool
um
so let's maybe make so how would we do
this first of all
um
the scene
the scene should probably have a Time
step
modifier
or time step scale or just a time scale
no I don't think so
okay that's it
um so now if I go into
play arm this is basically how it's
gonna work I think uh if we're going to
pull a um
if I'm
yeah the the targeting situation
yeah I didn't do that last thing though
that's okay
foreign
that's kind of cool
that muzzle flash is the worst thing
ever I made a perfect muzzle flash and
it's ruined now I don't know what Peter
did
with my muzzle flash
hanging off to me but he can't go off to
my muzzle flash
uh that's on the gun right
like what the heck did he do man why is
it like this big
is he having a laugh
where am I
okay that's still kind of lame
that muzzle flash
that's pretty dope though
all right cool so we can slow down time
that's nice
that makes it a bit cooler
um
I don't know I should probably
not tweak this anymore
I do like it more when it's a bit
more subtle
[Music]
we've got the upside down gun again
okay I think the other the other problem
is that that
I just want the muzzle flash to stay
there for like
a frame it's just because it's because
we've slowed down time
it ends up being uh longer
how does the gun do that now
that's better
yeah that's great all right whoops
midnight
exactly 12 a.m now
great
right so
basically
if I can just grab this and take it to
if I can just take this to
me
[Music]
so that's the General's tent and that's
basically done
uh
an outfit oh no it says upside down now
I mean back front now for flip to
whatever great all right weird lots of
weird stuff going on
uh let's build the Shader back
because I feel like there or something
there
foreign
great
why does that won't work
[Music]
no
what the heck
yeah really weird
that doesn't work
all these vulcaners they're all the same
yeah there's multiple threads thing
whatever
we might have to run a debug build
of this because it's just not working
yeah
thanks spectral for the five bucks
interesting to see you up to light how
much longer will you stream for also
thank you for teaching me programming a
lot from Melbourne uh you're welcome
um I don't know how long I'll stay out
for I kind of want I don't want to get
some sleep but it there's 11 hours left
uh until the end of the game Jam so
I don't know Peter's gonna wake up soon
because he isn't Sweden and uh Tim is
working hard
as well so there's three of us we might
be able to get some more work done like
Peter might take over when I go to sleep
but I don't know I was gonna maybe do a
24-hour stream but yeah
maybe not
I'm not yeah I I Won't Say I'm like
burned out it's just
it's there's been there's definitely
been some annoying things here
oh well look it works in debug are you
serious why
this is this is what we got this is
debug performance guys 11 FPS
why does it work in debug
and not release
that's so weird
my map looks like an actual real crash
that's not like a C sharp exception
huh
oh man
doing game jams with your own engine
seems like a great way to learn where to
improve yes
um we always
end up chain like changing a lot and
adding many features and stuff
but yeah
I feel like I've I remember this stuff
happening
why is this happening in release though
ah script component get instance oh I do
remember this
yeah yeah
yeah yeah I don't think oh man I know
exactly what this is oh this is annoying
I forgot that this this was a thing
this was this is because apparently
you can't do that as
ah it's yeah which of course makes sense
like yes
Ah that's the worst
um you can't do dot as
um in the oncreate function
which I did in one place
here like an enemy manager for example
so basically let's make this
be not done here
let's just make it that
errors are just visual Studios as tight
as I am honestly like these aren't
actually real errors it builds fine
um
and were there any other places that I
did that
yeah this so
let's also replace this with that
and anywhere else
no okay so this should now work
if I switch back to release uh well this
is for the
thing but if I go back to
Hazelnut and I just need to make sure
that I re-do the um
imaginary build the asset pack
don't worry about that
I should just uh maybe put remove that
break point
uh now if we're on the run time and
release hopefully it works
yep yeah so see it was just that for
some reason
all right so this is our little game
whoa he'll be spilling my coffee
not going to kill him
that's not good
well I can always run
yeah so there's still a few things
missing from the gameplay but
you know
and there's my tent
I don't know yeah I don't like this
it's almost hard to kill them because of
that
am I staying up until submission
probably not
but yeah there's still so much work to
do
but like audience don't like honestly I
because I have to do audio as well and
which I haven't even
Spiderman usually I do like
I have quite a bit of time to do audio
but
I don't need more
I don't know man I don't see how we're
gonna finish this
like I just feel like this is
what happened
I don't know to be honest it's just been
like stuff just
hasn't been working well like I feel
like
not Hazel though well I don't know I
said what I meant like developing games
is always harder than like actually
doing the engine because you're dealing
90 of the time with worse quality code
well no I think like for me it's two
things like the math with hexagons
screwed me up and no no sorry not with
hexagons with chunks and like
nothing to do with these cute little
innocent hexagons but like that screwed
me up a lot and that honestly I feel
like almost half a day you know
um
and just like stuff like trying to get
the guns forward Direction
and it's just like for some reason it's
weird and doesn't work I can't get the
barrel like I could not and I spent like
an hour trying to figure out like this
stupid barrel like position
like the front of the barrel and I just
can't get it like no matter what so at
the moment it's shooting from the origin
of the player like well no it's not
shooting from there but that's where the
ray gets drawn from which can be a
problem
uh because it might hit walls and stuff
sometimes
and put like an entity in front of the
boat there is an entity there man and I
just can't get its position like it's
not correct
and also Peter added a whole bunch of
weird custom code to the guns rotation
which like 10 of the time or even 30 of
the time means that it's flipped back to
front and like I'm not even gonna deal
with that I don't have time he's gonna
wake up soon he can deal with it he
wrote the code I don't want to take the
time to understand it and change it and
do whatever like he can just deal with
that
so like honestly it's just been all this
garbage like accumulation of little
things
that just sucks you know
because we were going to dinner last
night right and you were saying like
honestly I feel so I know like I know
everything is so great but then it's
like I it basically started in the
morning where I'm like let me just
quickly make the tents like be flat and
then I'm like how do I get the current
how do I if I have a world space
position how do I get the tile index so
I can get the tile entity
and that took like hours because there
were just all these edge cases and I was
just garbage but also because like I
don't know I should stop doing mathy
things in the morning because I just
can't think
like I'm really bad at math in the
morning
I don't know it's just all this little
little thing like I feel like
the amount of work that I've actually
gone got done today it looks like it
seems like a lot because the game was
very different in the morning but I feel
like it's like two hours worth of work
but it's been 12. it's been 13 hours
but I'm glad that at least the runtime
builds because that means we can
actually ship this if we want to but if
we want
yeah
and then it's like you know
we like aside from audio though I like I
wanted to put together a little tutorial
on there's still no real gameplay Loop
in the sense that like there is no
General there is no like
you know that's a bit annoying
like there's no like hey well done you
brought me my coffee
but like Peter can probably iron that
out should we have a voice like a
lioness
where's Peter he should be up by now
for him but he went to bed pretty yeah
but
he should be awake
Peter
Peter Peter Peter
yeah look we just have to like
basically do nothing apart from the game
Loop just because we need a game okay
as soon as we have that solid tested
then we can
work on something else
and like oh and then I start from audio
like I also kind of need to do the whole
UI situation
you know adding you adding UI to the
engine so that I can we can display the
things properly
what and you want to sleep tonight
well that's the thing
no well look I think music is important
for the game
I don't know about music I think like
just some Ambience and some gunfire but
like I don't know man
how do you want to spend the next
part of me is also just like what's the
point you know because what are we gonna
do we're gonna like
ship this we're gonna kill ourselves get
it out on time and then what is the
point like
you know what I mean like
the point I don't know
but no but I like the idea of the game
and I feel like it could be a really
cool beginning of like just
something else almost
like the world generation look is cool I
really like the aesthetic
what what does it look like with um The
Edge outline on
yeah I'd be curious
that should be pretty easy to turn on
just this
oh it's hazelnut
well oh I just think it's turned on ah
yeah no it's moderately
not that smart it's not that hard to to
do but I have to
enable it in the Shader as well
failed to compile
what
semicolon
no
why is it not compiling that Trader
fairly easy to turn on
Edge texture ah
no no it's because um
this needs to go up here so that
that's also included
um
maybe it works now
it doesn't seem like it
I don't know it's fine it's just
disables uh if I build the Shader pack
though
and now if I run the run time maybe
if we're lucky
we'll see it
yep
it looks kind of cool yeah
you almost can't tell your flowers
I think it's cool
oh yeah you're right
because I thought you you put like some
texture or something like that that
looks kind of cool it almost looks like
a comic book or something
I kind of like that
oh yeah did you notice that it's slow
motion when you shoot I should do that
right oh yeah you played it I think
where are the enemies I think this is
one of those seeds where all the enemies
spawn on the ground they fall off the
map
that can happen as ah here we go
see look it's when you aim it's slow
motion like say this is far this is a
normal and then that's slow
it's a physics actually everything's
slow yeah physics
rendering
frame rate
no the frame rate romances
that doesn't look bad actually
The Edge outline
the thing is we can submit pass the due
date like for critical bug fixes maybe
we should convert this to an extra game
and spend the next three weeks on it
that's funny
look see how their shotguns are oh no
they're fine I mean you can I thought
they were in fact because there's no
radio
which you should reuse the texture from
dichotomy from the red turconomic you
won this and this will be like this is
where all the players went from
dichotomy
well no I've already made a new player
model
I think if you pull the latest gameplay
you'll see it but I don't I don't have
it set up for the player yet because
Peter can do that
no I actually kind of like the airline
effect on the way yeah it looks kind of
cool like here
that looks kind of cool
and I think like the front of the
character as well like there's a bit
more to it it's such a good outline
effect I don't figure out where I
adapted it from I mean I don't remember
all right that's cool I found it on like
yeah I don't remember which one
no we're not gonna I don't think we're
gonna keep the outline effect
but it just looks cool
I'm telling you Hazel should should by
default with the outline effect that's
that's his thing you have to like jump
through so many Hoops to turn it off
you have to pay money for hazel to turn
it up
that's fine that's it
my coffee
not the coffee this is like you know how
like at Sunset comes or whatever the
Seinfeld do that
they just like end on a still frame
Seinfeld does that yeah
this is kind of like no and then the
executive producer
not the coffee it's funny because I
paused super paused like this great
because it's a screen capture so when I
hit Escape you'll probably see just the
dead play everything's all over
he's he's not dead but he's out of
coffee
because in our game
being dead is better than being out
yeah you can't die but you can lose your
copy
it's a lot like real life it's really an
allegory the game name
coffee to you
I'm annoyed with this guy trolling
from the atom is a moderator
the last straw was saying Bloom was
unnecessary
it's a short way to get banned
um
what's it called GTA wasted death
animation will be awesome yeah that
would be pretty cool
I'm not gonna animate the What's called
the general because that's gonna take
too long and I think I'm gonna scrub
during the redoing the player I don't
know like what are you doing the player
uh rather what I'll do is like make a
main menu like a nice main menu I think
okay because you have enough when you
play as it is and I'm kind of dumped on
yours because I'm like I guess if you're
chilling here you may as well do this
but considering how you have all this
stuff that you're not gonna get done
anyway I'll just I'm drinking kombucha
so yeah I'll get started on that pretty
soon
but that's if we had like an extra day
if it was like four days
I just feel like I would have
yeah
I don't know man
well the thing is Peter can do some
stuff right
I'm sure he can do a lot of stuff
because if he could just do the rest of
like that like if I if I just can focus
on two things that the whole tutorial
text which involves you know adding that
support for UI kind of to head to the
engine and also the audio
maybe that
would be enough
what's it called uh we're not putting
the sandbags and tanks oh that no we
probably should but I don't know like
but on the other hand like How's that
gonna look you know
I don't know I feel like there's a lot
of death flew by
like I honestly don't feel like it's
been three days already
it feels like two days
it's weird
all right well I guess I can maybe start
on the music
what do you think the music should be
intense I mean we could just cut it and
just have ambience
like I could that's the name of the game
Ambience no coffee intense but it's not
intense it's intense
that's intense yeah
all right okay
[Music]
after that I'm done
a wild piano appeared
oh I don't know
[Music]
I feel uninspired
Bad News Bears
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
kind of like
I think this one should be an acoustic
guitar soundtrack
[Music]
briefly E flat minor to B7 major
thank you
[Music]
sounds like garbage hey you know that
sad freaking music and attack of Titan
when everyone's dying that might fit no
I don't know that
I haven't seen Attack on Titan have you
you have probably yeah yeah is it good
is it as is it as hyped as everyone says
yeah I like it I like some anime yeah I
like the Ghibli movies it is a bit like
outfit
in the sense that you kind of a lot of
the time you're watching people
right
yeah no I've seen that I've seen those
spots that was that Metallica privilege
yeah the I was playing um
ah Nothing Else Matters before yeah
just naturally stumbled into it but it
was actually on my mind when I was
thinking about a soundtrack for like a
war movie I don't know why but I feel
like that that kind of fits well
maybe some military music
oh
Star Wars
soundtrack
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
haven't seen the game yet what's the
thing of feeling I don't know man
I feel like I'm gonna I'm not gonna
finish this game
so I'm kind of over it
a little bit don't let Tim here though
even though he's literally two meters
away from me
can you do Jurassic Park I don't know I
don't remember that song that music
being minor natural yesterday at dinner
it was like building into an intense C
major
[Music]
thank you
a minor why are you guys just saying
like
words
[Laughter]
I was gonna say twitch chat rights game
music but actually it's YouTube chat
[Music]
for three days what kind of competition
even is there
quite a quite a lot surprisingly
especially when you don't even have to
use your own Assets in the jam you just
have to be like I stole this and that
in the whole of Mountain King but on
coffee
[Music]
I barely remember I don't really
remember that I'm just playing it by you
card using the coding using that piano
keyboard that won't be sick man I should
make a video where I map every key on my
keyboard to this key and be like guys I
got a new keyboard
check it out
that'd be somewhat efficient because
there's obviously more keys on the ps91
keys here right that's more than like
the computer keyboard
so you could it could be cool you could
be like
when I press this key up here it's the
equivalent of two or three keyboard
Strokes in one hit
and then
yeah the the I just love like the panel
is you're gonna be holding shift and
then like like left hour left hour left
out right right
oh yeah
oh but you get that you get this the the
uh note to actually play as well
to play well you know it's not it's not
it's not just like silence it actually
like plays what you type
which is gonna sound horrendous moving
your arm further is less efficient LOL
thank you guys for critically analyzing
my idea
why do you do so long streams that's
unhealthy it's called a 72 hour game Jam
I'm getting mean it's time to stop
streaming
main Channel
nice chill game
dude took that piano keyboard comments
to Heart
yeah I did if you can steal assets just
take the soundtrack from the movie 1917.
yeah
could do that
thank you
great time to review pull requests yeah
I remember that
foreign
[Music]
uh
Sahan simmer
did he do Interstellar yeah
yeah
I like the interstellar seam
maybe I can just copy into Stella
how does that go again
[Music]
no I've got it in my head I just can't
play it
[Music]
oh yeah
that's right I think this one
[Music]
foreign
but yeah
[Music]
that's it
so I could have steal that
no we'll notice I'll just you I'll just
do it in different case basically a
complete unique set of nerds
this doesn't suit the game though
[Music]
thank you
to The Dark Knight theme I don't know I
don't know that one like because then I
I haven't heard it I think what's the
other one Inception dream is collapsing
or whatever
how does that go
um because I like that one there's two I
like from inception time and I guess
James I don't I can't like I'm just
brain dead right now though like I I
literally don't remember the melody
but anyway it doesn't matter there's a
little waste of time
do you use Auto hotkey yeah yeah that's
how I'm playing
um I'm actually running a script
um I used I use AutoCAD key I do
actually use Auto hookway for exactly
one thing and it's for keeping Windows
always on top
because it's good
uh
ask chat gbt
that's not a bad idea man
I'm gonna ask chat GPT
which
I don't remember how to log into that
everything
it might be on my laptop it might be
already locked in here I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask Chad CBT for a war chord
progression
and Melody line Maybe
and we're gonna go with that
all right listen here chat GPT
your connection was interrupted
well my internet is probably working
considering I think I'm live
and I have to log in
ah yeah this is a disaster
chargpt ain't great for music really but
can't it just tell me like in words what
to do
pretty sure I made I made my account
with um
Google
sorry I think I should try logging in
with my Google account I guess
this just sucks
I hate everything
you guys should just be happy that
you're not in this situation where
you're
like doing it making a game for a game
jam and not sleeping
all right okay I'm in
nah well yeah but I feel bad for doing
that so I'm kind of working on music
all right
um I need I okay hello
chat GPT
sorry for calling so late
I'm in a bit of a pickle
I am doing a game Jam
and I desperately
yeah desperately
need
to write some music for it
uh
please
it's a war it's a game set in a war zone
but there are
some cartoony
graphics
so it's a bit more chill
please let me know
what chord progression
would suit such an affair
yours
forever
all right let's see what he says
no I'm not sharing my screen so my
laptop Peter wake up hello hello Cherno
don't worry about the late call I'm
always here to help you out based on
your description of the game setting you
may want to consider using a minor chord
progression thank you as they can convey
a sense of tension and conflict that
fits with the war zone setting however
since the graphics are cartoony and the
mood is supposed to be network error
and the mood is supposed to be somewhat
chill you might not want to make the
music too dark or intense oh but I do
one option this is hilarious it
literally says one option could be a
minor minor two major five minor one
progression which is commonly used in
jazz and can network error
like I'm not making this up
it literally like
all the fluff is there
but then when it gets to the business
but then as soon as it's like actually
laying down the law
so what did it say two five one so that
that would be like
[Music]
this one the inverse which is commonly
used in jazz and can and that's it
why why is there a network error I'm
connected I've been connected the whole
time you're my chat you PT just say you
don't want to talk to me you have to
fake like oh I'm going through a tunnel
the heck
oh here we go it's back
is that what what is that is that a
diminished
I've never seen that sign in music
before
it's like a it's like the zero through a
to me it's like Swedish like this it's
like it looks like Sweden what is that
guys do you know what that is it says b
and then it's like a zero but it's like
got a line through it seven
for some reason my gut says diminished
which would be like what
no what's the diminished again it's
that's diminished right
it's a minor but it's flat flat five
halftime
it's a half diminish what's a half
diminished I don't know what that is
yeah just a little music world real
quick what is I'm just gonna ask it why
I'm asking you guys I got asked chat jbt
it's a shorthand way of saying be half
diminished seventh chord yeah because
it's got seven
so in the context of the a minor scale
it would be the uh both on the seventh
degree of the scale bdfa oh well that's
what I played
[Music]
I just didn't play the seventh
and again in network error you pile of
garbage
why why is it dropping out
all right so it's suggesting uh b b
diminished B diminished seventh which is
this followed by an E7
followed by an A minor seven
[Music]
foreign
back to the B diminished is a bit weird
[Music]
I like the em
the E7
[Music]
I mean so I guess a b diminished seventh
is literally just a
it's a dis it's a D Minor six as well
but it's just the root is a b instead of
the sixth adding a sixth
fascinating
we in the orchestra yes worst Orchestra
ever
um
someone's saying a minor seven
General plays chat chords uh a minor
seven
D minor seven
[Music]
B minor seven flat five are good Peter's
here thank God I was getting sick of
this B minor seven flat five
uh isn't that just a diminished
or is it B minor seven add the flat five
no that's that's like a flat 13 or
whatever and then an E7
[Music]
good Peter I've gone crazy uh it's good
that you're here
um I should probably
update you uh
[Music]
I guess I'll do a call and show you and
stream
what I've done
so Tim and I decided to scrap the game
and start a completely new project
good news
and we're using Unity
on let's look at us oh yeah yeah we're
using Godot
I'd rather die
I've been gone for six hours man what
happened
he's gonna he's gonna regret sleeping
for that long
all right all right Peter
uh I guess I'll do a call
and I'll show stream as well
um how do I Discord
all right Peter in the house
um okay let me show you I mean the
game's basically done it's just not
really done but it's like kind of done
well it's not done like there's
there's it's hard to explain I'll just
show you
actually you know what I'll show you in
the run time that's how done it is
screw the editor we don't need that
boys
let me
no actually I'll show you in a minute
let me I want to get rid of the outline
effect actually it doesn't matter you
can you can I turned the outline effect
for fun we just on for fun we just
wanted to see what it looked like all
right so basically you drop in uh
tab show you can see my screen yeah
yeah tab just shows you where to go so
initially it shows you to get the coffee
basically so you walk you get you go to
the tent which is on a perfectly flat
terrain uh there's a gun that spawns
here I don't know about the your text or
whatever so you pick that up and then
you pick up the coffee
um now it magically changes to show you
that you need to go to
the general tent
so you basically you have your gun and
you're basically walking to journal 10.
now enemies should be spawning uh
there's a chance sometimes that they
don't really spawn for all chunks but
you can see that here they are
um so you can aim at them by pressing
right click and if you do time slows
down as you can see you can shoot at
them
kill them and uh
well yeah pick up their weapons and
whatever
you can see I probably lost a bit of
coffee there
um I'm not gonna pick up their weapons
uh and um yeah shift is to Sprint which
is you can just kind of speed around it
I made this print speed fast mostly I
added Sprint initially just to be able
to quickly debug and test stuff but you
can see this is the General's tent where
I'm supposed to leave the coffee but at
the moment it's exactly the same so
there's no actual General and there's no
way to leave the coffee here really in
fact it's a duplicate so you can pick up
another coffee which is fine in af2
um
but the shooting mechanic kind of works
right so you can see it Well yeah if I
hold right click that's kind of like the
aim down sight
um yeah so it zooms in the field of view
and so does by the way moving the camera
so moving the camera in like this
actually it zooms it in a bit like in
terms of field of view that's why you
can't see the text here
but I'm gonna have a different
like what I'm probably gonna add a
little screen space UI to Hazel very
quickly
um because we kind of need it for the
for the tutorial text
um and yeah if you hold right click you
can see that Crosshair just targets the
closest entity within a certain range
and you can see the player rotates to
face him as well
um well one of these two basically
depending on which one it chooses it can
switch targets very quickly
and there's no accuracy or anything like
I said it just shoots perfectly
um
yeah
you can see I can kind of kind of kill
them so in that sense it's kind of
working but also like the right yeah
you're definitely right about the
raycasts being weird and also what seems
to happen is sometimes this gun here
will just be backwards it'll be upside
down and facing that way
I noticed that I thought I was getting
the rotations wrong in the code
but then they were right and I thought I
had fixed it but then they were wrong
again
and I don't know why yeah it's really
weird
um I just also think that you should
probably never use
said it you should probably almost never
set the rotations using Euler angles
like I just feel like set them using
quotations like as in just use set
rotation and that would probably be
better
but also that's what I ended up doing
for a player in the camera
yeah but also um
uh what they're gonna say yeah there's
like the weirdest thing ever because
I've been trying to get the gun to shoot
from the barrel
however like I literally cannot like if
I try and get the world space transform
and World space position of like this
entity that happens to be here it just
gets me like it all the way out here and
like it just doesn't work man like I
don't know what it is
like it's as if it and it depends on the
rotation as well it's like it's like
it's not actually relative rotation even
though that's parented to this it's
really weird so I just gave up and at
the moment it's just he just shoots from
the origin of the actual player because
that's pretty relaxed no origin of the
player plus one meter on the Y so from
here yeah
um
because otherwise it's just like
ridiculous yeah I don't know why it's
super strange
um and yeah sometimes like Ms have been
annoying because like if I stand up on
this hill for example and I shoot like
you can kind of see that like the let me
just point this way the the barrel
of the gun is technically able to shoot
the thing but he goes through the ground
like the original play goes through the
ground so therefore of course that
doesn't work because you're shooting
this but it clearly looks like it should
work so there's a bit
if there's a few different weird issues
um
but like you know the game works like I
would preferably you would basically fix
the rest of the gameplay and also add
the whole General thing I would like to
get some sleep but aside from that I can
basically add all of the tutorials so
I'll add tutorial text uh but also add
rent like you know add some like screen
space text components or something to
Hazel that will just appear on top of
everything in screen space all the time
like as in they'll they won't be
obscured by the dev buffer or anything
MLB in screen space kind of like well
literally like you know this text that's
in the runtime
yeah um
and uh and then I'll do that and then
also I have to do the audio and the
music somehow like I don't know about
the music might just do Ambience but
they probably should there needs to be
like shooting sound effects and stuff
and I don't even know if the audio
engine works
because I think
um I think even Emily managed to get
something working with audio or Medics
so Windows definitely work in that case
also did you disable the spotlight
Shadows
uh I didn't yeah sorry that's
seems to be broken
for some reason
also my lie is like flickering
why is my life flickering
no
yeah anyway
and uh I don't know man and for the ammo
encounter like I feel like I wouldn't
have an American counter I would just
like either like you try and shoot and
it just clicks
like you don't know how much ammo you
have or even you could get someone to
like just shout I'm out of ammo or
something or need near Hammer yeah check
check this check his supply lines yeah
um I don't know something like that like
Yeah just something a bit more like
because I don't know man like this like
just text on screen like first of all
that gives me Forest Vibes and second of
all
and second of all like I don't know I
just yeah I prefer not to have that yeah
we could change it pretty easily I think
yeah because we have like it's called
challenge why is that weird
detection without bouncing great yeah
it's like bouncing
when I move the camera the texture is it
yeah that's baked into the texture what
maybe it's something to do with the
outline Channel that's what I think yeah
I think so it's got to be right wow
never say It's gotta be
why not
don't ask this is a nice looking tent
thanks
all right so it's the general model uh
done yes Tim has it uh well I'm working
on it right now but yeah it's
essentially going to be the player model
but with a different hat that's it
oh that sounds good because uh with Ian
being in the state that he is I feel
like I need to step up and take
something off his plate so I want to do
the main menu as soon as that's done so
that's why I'm kind of rushing to finish
the models and get on to that because
the longer I can spend another battle
um and then yeah maybe
maybe have a look at like recording some
Audio for
like
just to give the ambience of like World
War One like I'm Alabama or whatever
like supply lines it's all about silence
you know whatever
um but that's a stretch goal for me
anyway first main menu
okay
in that case so I'm I'm gonna put some
I'm gonna start by just making where we
can spawn in the general
um and actually like
deliver the coffee anyway
we need a complete a complete Game loop
as soon as possible like above fixing
rotations all that doesn't matter if we
don't have a like a loop yeah these
rotations if they were perfect they
wouldn't do anything
um yeah
um and after that we can get to the bugs
in the order yeah
um yeah because all the general deliver
the coffee yeah
and the gameplay is like there it's done
yeah and start fixing and polishing yeah
what's it called Peter if uh after this
if me and you can hop on a call uh
because I animated an enemy player and
like I wasn't sure how to set up so I
just created a prefab called animated
player and so if we just swap that model
in uh and double check that the compass
model is swapped incorrectly which I
think it should be I just swapped in the
mesh basically
um but yeah just double check that the
assets I've done so far already part of
the game because I don't want to be
having to do it in the last hour you
know like if they're done they should be
already part of the game and test it and
whatnot oh
yeah that sounds good
um
okay I also spoiled the general in the
goal tent
um an ad 11 the coffee which beats the
game
um
sounds good okay well first step I think
is let me just like push and stuff so
that you can yeah actually okay uh I
added I added a nice thing to the engine
where you can right click on an entity
and click on parent
because like we just could not unparent
entities like literally Tim was trying
to find the magic pixel and that didn't
work
well it it should because it's not just
one pixel on that well it's on the right
look man H I tried he tried like really
I haven't had any issues with it well
Tim you're the witness yeah no you
couldn't when it's a full uh full scene
hierarchy there's a hard time on
parenting you know that people like from
forest do you remember how hard it is
well you can just drag it to the right
side of this in hierarchy panel yeah but
I didn't wait and try that I think no I
tried that but the reason why that
wasn't working at least I suspect I
don't know why is because uh Jan had his
docked on the opposite side of the
screen and Jan has that bug where it's
like his stuff gets cut out halfway
through the screen so maybe that has
something to do with it but huh yeah
that would probably do it
yeah that whole thing needs rework into
the way
um yeah there's a lot of stuff in the
engine I added like a uh
you can build you can set the time scale
on the scene through C sharp which is
how we do the Slime arm
what do we do in dichotomy
um I had a multiplier in C sharp that I
just multiplied with
um
about the poem in like most in whatever
scripts needed it yeah the difference
here the difference here is the physics
engine against the Delta time as well
yeah it's a it's an engine side thing
yeah
whereas in dichotomy it wasn't but it
slowed down the axis but I guess because
they weren't physics yeah
yeah
we were rotating them like normal yeah
the only thing they use physics for was
the television
uh
that's probably
oh yeah I should turn off this
um yeah so that's kind of like the the
end that we don't need
I had to go and adding transparency to
the end it wouldn't be a a lot of dare
without me trying to sneak in
transparency quickly
under the rug yeah
engine stuff
too tired too write a message
sorry
you guys can't do that under me because
I'm the boss that's funny because young
committed like just the them final too
tight to write a message sorry or
whatever I think yeah you should have
seen the essay he wrote to chat gbt like
it was a formal introduction dear Chad
gbt how are you going on this fine
evening I'm very tired we're in a rush
for a game engine get to the point can
you please help me write a song
yeah I asked for a chord progression
uh okay yeah did it work uh yeah I mean
it gave me a chord progression but like
you know
I could also write down some random
calls on a piece of paper
all right
um I'm just gonna give you like all this
stuff and like good luck because I don't
like I'm not even like I'm telling you I
don't oh cross it you probably don't
need that but you're getting it oh the
mesh there's a Crosshair mesh yeah I
couldn't get I couldn't get a texture
with transparency for the Crosshair so
we have a 3D mesh which is fine what's
fine yeah it looks kind of cool
uh
uh shooting and
game
what did you push stuff
that's that registry
yes it's just that one thing
I'm not running hazelnut am I no good
all right I've done some pushing
uh yeah all right
um
yeah
that's it
do you kind of know what you're doing on
uh
hey Peter can you can you pull the game
engine code and just make sure that
everything runs and that Jan doesn't
have a secret stash it didn't get pushed
by boxing because this happened in the
last two days already
a secret stash
like twice you've left office and Peter
hops on the call like 30 minutes after I
think I think I'm gonna go up at the
audio not screw the Audio I think I'm
gonna go like to
oh yeah we briefly considered still
stealing the interstellar soundtrack
[Music]
um but but
um
what was I gonna say I'm gonna go
probably get some sleep maybe I'll get
up around 6 a.m though and that will
that will give me like I don't know five
or so hours maybe four hours by the time
I get in four hours to like
finish the game but then you'll have
about five or so hours
yeah because there's no if you're gonna
be doing stuff there's no there's not
much point in me doing stuff and maybe
I'll get in and I'll do the I'll do the
engine side like UI components so that
we can do the tutorial and then also
I'll do the audio which obviously
doesn't touch anything
in the morning that's basically it
yeah
it would be nice if we could get like a
little soundtrack down but I don't think
that's that's necessary
worst case
soundtrack doesn't change the gameplay
what if I just do like a
what if I do a stupid version of
interstellar it's like
[Music]
and it's just like some kind of like
like budget version that's like clearly
not you know therefore the copyright
strikes not gonna happen because that's
fair use right
it's gone blue
I don't think Peter's too keen on that
[Music]
that would make it scary all right
yeah especially if everything is a minor
chord
foreign
distorted
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm probably not gonna do like the gum
pickup Behavior stuff because
it works the way it is now and I don't
want to risk just completely puking it
yeah instead I might just focus on like
polishing and fixing issues after I've
done like the gameplay stuff yeah
well yeah most important thing is
basically get that General tent in
because like 10 only speaking even
though the game is like rough around the
edges
it's like
it's evidence
it's yeah like it it as long as the
general is there you can technically
take the coffee from the first hand to
the second tent like
and oh and obviously you should make it
so that we can lose
[Music]
like as in if you spill all the coffee
then game over and maybe enter to try
again and maybe it will regenerate the
world
you can just reload the whole game
basically just reload the scene or
whatever
I'll probably if you reload the scene
does it
um
like clear static things
oh no because it reloads the assembly
yeah yeah that's right I forgot that's
easy enough but no but it's okay I
didn't do anything static
I have although I think nothing truly
matters technically and I also did
I didn't clear
that kind of stuff so yeah well actually
yeah it should be fine
and if it's not I'll just modify the
runtime project to call it
yeah yeah
[Music]
it's like E flat
okay now I'm gonna make sure that uh
yeah doesn't have a secret stash of code
somewhere yeah can you yeah make sure
that everything works and then I'll go
to sleep
yeah uh so yeah you were playing yeah
it's yes yeah that's yep that one the
main one that's the main one
right that's the only one I ever opened
oh I opened your compass one briefly to
see how to make that work
okay good and you have like you know I
did yeah you do have a gun yep
[Music]
um no
here's the tent now
oh that's fine that's fine no that's
actually fine
oh that that's fine that just means some
of the tiles couldn't be found but it's
probably kind of on a trunk boundary but
it doesn't matter
still work
[Music]
you didn't add aiming for the controller
but I can add that
oh yeah it says I didn't know I didn't
know if controller support should be
like a priority
[Music]
it's not a problem
yeah okay
[Music]
cool
um sounds good
but it's fine script was scripting
printing oh print
ing
printing with the controller ah
sprinting yeah yeah I I kind of try to
make that work but it doesn't like if
you look at if you look at the car
there's an is sprinting or can't I don't
know it's like some kind of sprinting
ball in and it tries to check the uh
something but it doesn't work
[Music]
it's the very last function in motion
player and you can see it tries to see
if the left joystick is pressed
but that doesn't work
[Music]
oh you probably won't yeah press this
only for one
for you
yeah that's probably yeah
okay well then just change it to that
yeah
what's the difference between down and
held held is everything after that
[Music]
both like okay yeah Tim already
explained it Peter stop talking
it's the latency it's the sweet it's the
latency all the way to Sweden you can't
keep up
[Music]
so is everything everything's working
for you
so I should go to sleep yeah
[Music]
all right good night Peter dismissed
young all right excellent my favorite
thing to be is dismissed
all right
goodbye Chad it's been real
I'm gonna get some sleep
uh I'll see you guys in like
five-ish hours I guess
hopefully the boys
The Boys carry the team here
all right later
I can do a volume with the guitar
but the problem with this stupid thing
is
I don't know where to stop it because
like if I stop it too early cuts off the
stream oh well that's clearly done
thank you